pase rodeado de las obras de artistas
como rubens Tiziano Goya o Velázquez es
ahora un plan alternativo para empezar
la noche madrileña el primer sábado de
cada mes el Museo del Prado Abre de
manera gratuita sus puertas
consiste en abrir por la noche para
enseñar el museo de otra forma un poco
diferente queremos
enseñarlo Pues abriéndolo poco a poco
por partes y siempre con algo que llame
un poquito más la atención que no sea la
visita habitual es bueno pues tenemos un
programa especial de música dedicado
específicamente al museo
entre las obras más famosas que se
podían visitar esta noche en el Museo
del Prado está el famoso cuadro de
Velázquez las meninas Pues la verdad que
es maravilloso verlo con muy poquita
gente ver las meninas Así es una pasada
habías visto ya el cuadro de las meninas
antes
y me ha gustado mucho
que dar acceso a la cultura a cualquier
persona que no sea los colectivos que
tienen gratuito como estudiantes gente
mayorita está genial y creo que es algo
súper novedoso estaba muy bien vendríais
si no fuera gratis por supuesto si
estuviese que tuviésemos que pagar
alguna contribución voluntaria por poder
tener la oportunidad de entrar en el
Prado en una noche como ésta Pues por
supuesto estaríamos encantados de
hacerlo también el Museo del Prado ya
cuenta con algunos días de gratuidad Y
estos son los más visitados por eso los
organizadores quieren que con esta
iniciativa aumenten las visitas a esta
pinacoteca española que en 2022
alcanzaron los dos millones y medio de
visitantes algo menos de los 3,2
millones que había antes de la pandemia
en 2019